restarting your career in a new country
that too in a new sector after a career
break is anything but easy I faced my
share of challenges and I'm glad that I
took the right decision at the right
time to upskill myself this course
helped me to restart my career in
digital marketing after a gap of three
years hi my name is smriti and I am a
digital marketer by profession
I am a mother of two beautiful children
and we live in Atlanta Georgia I got
married and I moved to States in 2014
back in India I was working as a PR
consultant when I moved here I got my
work permit and I landed my first job
here that was in Comcast it was a sales
profile I worked there for some time and
in 2018 when I was expecting my second
child I decided to take a break from
work
and I was blessed with a daughter
so in 2021 when my daughter turned three
and my son was a little older so I
thought now this is the time I can focus
on my career things did not work out for
me as I thought it would I did my
research and I realized that digital
marketing is a growing field I already
had experience in sales and public
relations so I wanted to learn digital
marketing so I opted a professional
certification program in digital
marketing from Purdue University offered
by simply learn this course gave me an
understanding about SEO social media
marketing web analytics and email
marketing these courses are very well
designed for beginners the best part
about this course are the live classes
that keeps you on your schedule our
Mentor was very well informed about each
topic take on the basis of my past
experience and on my newly developed
skill I landed my first freelance
project with a company called country
Edge this happened when I completed my
certification I am working with them the
best part about this job is it is remote
I can stay at home I can be with my kids
and I can also focus on my hobbies too
multitasking can be overwhelming
sometimes but if you have the right
skill you can get rid of all the
obstacles that come your way